[Applaus]
ich finde ja in den fraktionsräumen der
grünen und hier wurde heute bei der
ersten hochrechnung frenetisch bejubelt
tarek al wazir als er die bühne betreten
hat ist minuten lang überhaupt nicht zu
wort gekommen
die grünen haben ihr ergebnis fast
verdoppelt das ist natürlich ein
riesenerfolg auch bundesweit ist das ein
erfolg für die grünen denn sie sind
weiter im aufwind wir sind die gewinner
dieses wahlabends und darauf können wir
stolz sein nur was man sagen muss im
entstand jetzt ist die fortsetzung der
schwarz-grünen koalition höchstens
hauchdünn möglich also dass bleibt noch
spannend hier im großen sitzungssaal der
cdu da war es um 18 uhr als die ersten
hochrechnungen bekannt wurden doch sehr
sehr still
nur vereinzelt ein ganz kleines bisschen
applaus als aber dann heraus kamen dass
ein schwarz grünes bündnis doch noch
weiterhin für die regierung reichen
könnte ja da wurde der applaus ein
bisschen lauter man könnte vielleicht
sagen die cdu hat glück im unglück
wir haben schmerzliche verlust erlitten
das macht uns demütig das nehmen wir
ernst wir haben aber auch gesehen es
lohnt sich zu kämpfen volker bouffier
hat auch in seiner rede ganz klar gesagt
man hat uns bei 24 25 prozent erwartet
wir haben fast 28 prozent geschafft das
ist natürlich ein ganz ganz herber und
deutlicher verlust aber sie sind
weiterhin die stärkste partei
sie sagen wir haben gute politik gemacht
in hessen und das ist ein so schlechtes
ergebnis geworden ist das liegt an
berlin
wir wussten dass das im wahlkampf ist
wie noch nie erlebt haben
ein wahlkampf der natürlich ganz stark
überlagert war vom meinungsbilder großen
koalition in berlin da muss man nicht
drumrumreden und die botschaft dieses
abends für die berliner parteien jedoch
die regierung tragen ist doch klar
die menschen wünschen sich weniger
streit mehr sachorientierung der lösung
räder bouffier noch die cdu könne
natürlich glücklich sein damit dass die
zehn prozentpunkte verloren haben es ist
sieht wohl so aus dass die grünen von
einer insgesamt erfolgreichen
regierungspolitik mehr profitiert haben
als die cdu den grünen ist der erfolg
nur so zugeflogen
die cdu hat verloren das sollte in der
cdu anlass einmal darüber nachzudenken
was vielleicht auch in der darstellung
der politik anders gemacht werden
sollten
ich stehe das ist ein lokal unfassbaren
verfolgt die spd in hessen
das ergebnis der landtagswahl um 18 uhr
war es schon so dass die leute sich hier
vor die bühne gestellt haben und haben
das ergebnis mit dem gewissen gleichmut
entgegengenommen ein schwerer und ein
bitterer abend für die hessische spd
es war relativ klar dass sich die
prognosen durchsetzen würden der letzten
tage und das hat auch die erste prognose
gezeigt 20 prozent da liegt die spd
fehler will man aber im hessischen
landesverband nicht bei der eigenen
wahlkampfführung sehen da war der
dreiklang ganz klar bildung wohnen und
anbindungen von stadt und land sondern
schiebt es vor allen dingen auf die
bundespolitik auf die große koalition
aber auch auf die bundes spd hat
thorsten schäfer gümbel davon gesprochen
dass man kein rückenwind bekommen hätte
sondern regelrecht sturmböen aus berlin
das ergebnis zeigt sehr eindeutig dass
die möglichkeiten begrenzt sind gegen
einen übermächtigen bundestrend mit den
eigenen themen im land zu gewinnen
60 jahre lang hat in hessen nina andere
partei auch nur ein direktmandat
gewonnen außer cdu und spd und jetzt
verlieren diese beiden parteien jeweils
zehn prozentpunkte das ist schon
dramatisch
also wir stecken glaube ich in hessen
auch von der neuordnung der
parteipolitischen antreten
[Musik]
[Applaus]